hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm a Marvel shill hell yeah we're here
today to talk about Captain Marvel a
spoiler talk we saw for a second time
over at screen axis will be a podcast
spoiler like discussion there will be
timestamps in the description box for
you guys to work off of if you want to
skip around and whatnot we have some
notes here so that way you know talking
points before going into this review
though I did want to say that we're
going to be doing a separate video it's
probably be uploaded a little bit after
this that because we we do know how some
of the politics surrounding this film
outside have affected a lot of the
previewing experience and the actual
viewing experience whole conversation a
whole conversation and also yeah cuz on
our non-spoiler review it's about like
30 to 35% or dislikes on it and so we're
gonna do is we're gonna react to some of
the comments and go over a lot of those
things brie Larson's comments political
agendas feminism you know all those fun
things surrounding the film because we
got some opinions on it but you know for
this spoiler talk and I'm sure some
shades of gray of that will be in this
discussion but we're gonna keep that to
a minimum as much as possible here
because we want to talk about just the
movie itself the execution of it itself
in its spoiler talk so keep a lookout
for that talk that's gonna be a fun one
we've never does something like that
where we like go through the comments
and everything I've never done anything
like that
inject ourselves into a medley yeah not
takes it's gonna be it's gonna be quite
an interesting experience on both of our
ends and one thing I want to clarify
because we did watch this a second time
and I'll say this get ready to hit that
dislike button I liked him more the
second time I watched it if you guys
watch our non spoiler John was more
enthusiastic about it than I was I was
pretty much like everything I my basic
non-spoiler breakdown of it was I
thought supporting cast was really great
it was it was a really funny movie that
something I didn't really touch on in
non-spoiler but that's a big part of why
I ultimately recommended it was because
I did laugh a lot
I thought the visuals were spectacular
in the movie the action was really good
but some some moments not so great the
me and one thing we didn't touch on too
was the music is also very very good in
the movie as well so there was plenty
enough to recommend it my main issue was
brie Larson's performance I thought it
was a two-dimensional character didn't
really connect with her role I couldn't
tell if it was just the directing or if
it was just her performance in general I
will say this that watching this a
second time
I liked her more I didn't fall in love
with her performance I didn't fall in
love with the character of Carol Danvers
but I got more of what was going on what
she was doing and that's why you know
some people were like this doesn't make
any sense if you know Greg just talking
bad about a real arson performance why
would you recommend this movie that
offer I can sell out female propaganda
I'm like well no that's not it it's that
there's more to this movie than just
brie Larson movie a lot of different
movies yes and you can like some of them
but actually not others and are all
frizzy and all fairness rewatching it I
did kind of forget when we were
reviewing that there were moments where
I was charmed by her even though I felt
that was very surface performance the
first time around I still found plenty
of moments where I did find her overall
pretty charming so if I probably say
this in the next video - if you're not
open-minded to hearing what we have to
say about this movie because we're gonna
go over some pros and cons with the film
and if you're not open-minded to hearing
it or not open-minded to respectfully
disagree or if you're just not open to
the idea that people could possibly like
this yeah it's just a movie then okay
stay if you want go for it make the
right choice and we also we usually do
our spoiler talks for our talking points
we tend to save like the best stuff for
last but rather than worrying about
making sure we get the because there are
things with movies like this where if we
don't touch on it people will be like
why didn't you talk about this and we're
just gonna talk about those that's like
our first 14 things here we're going in
order of importance we're a they're just
get
goes out of the way and then move on and
also we're sitting about our windows
obviously the light changing a lot it's
because the Sun keeps coming in and out
miracle of nature yeah yeah well first
off thanks to screen X yeah okay no this
was not a press screening by any means
this was it was just that the screen
next leader and the people behind screen
actual are willing to kompis some
tickets to go watch it for their
experience and there's the one part of
the podcast was footage playing over it
because it's one of those things where
is a center screen and then it
encompasses the rest of the theater on
the left and right side of you if that
peripheral vision and I got to tell you
guys like it really does help with an
immersive experience there especially in
its space sequences any of its like
crazy visual moments in this movie it
really does engross you throughout the
movie and it's it a quite a lot actually
yeah sometimes we're like screen x or
imax formats you you know it's when
movies do IMAX and they convert to full
format it's really intermittent and in
this movie they do it quite a bit
yeah and so I want to say thank you to
guys before that because I would love to
go to screen X again and at a great time
experience I recommend watching it in
that format so first this boiler thing
to talk about that immediately got an
instant applause from the crowd both
times we watch it cuz first time was a
Disney press screening but those Disney
press ratings tend to have a mixture
it's not just press yeah there's a lot
of people who are just audience comers
who got tickets yeah seems like those
are always kind of a hodgepodge of press
yeah like a few regular audience people
and then like the folks who would show
up like influencers yeah yeah like their
tears or something yeah and then this
one just primarily regular coercive and
this starts off with this cool Stanley
trippy you know how those the Marvel
opening logo tensile characters and how
it's always evolved and this one was
just all bunch of the Stanley
appearances which was great and on the
second viewing I actually didn't notice
this until the second time I watched it
cuz when you watch these their first
time a look at like is that couldn't be
Stanley yeah yeah Stanley and then I
noticed this time he kept repeating the
same line yeah trust me trust me yeah or
something like that right
yeah and I saw he was reading a script
and you said this is the mall rats and
the first time I saw it I didn't I
thought it was just a plain white script
yeah the second time I realized they had
a bright red cover with the word mall
rats on it yeah yeah I noticed that
here's in that movies so yeah it's like
an inside joke I love it for we do
reactions on this channel one of my
favorite reactions to ever watch or
Kevin Smith's reactions and man I really
want to hear what he has to say about
that I don't know if they got his
permission to do it or if they just
threw it in there I feel like he knows
that yeah he's kind of like the
Godfather you know you're jolly uncle a
film community especially for like
comic-book tentpole movies so I bet that
was cleared no III was a great cameo
wonderful tribute and then you know
other thing to Marvel Marvel is a woman
[ __ ] [ __ ] what's she doing behind woman
with female body parts get a
y-chromosome why don't you I know it's
been a an argument for switching up
genders or races ethnicities and films
before and you know like you know that
feminist angle that people talk about
with them washing [ __ ] for me in the
movie itself though for someone who's
not familiar with him who Marvel is I
wasn't bothered I thought it actually
fits with the context because they kind
of treat Marvel as a phim as a mother
figure to Carol Danvers in this movie so
I thought that makes it more effective
especially when you're hopping in and
out of the Supreme intelligence yeah and
because that's like oh she can't
remember her past but this person is a
reflection of someone who was very
important to her so having this mother
like figure I actually thought was
pretty effective for the movie you know
she has like a [ __ ] dad but a a good but
a strong female figure in her life as
Carol Danvers so for me it doesn't
really like when I think about that even
if it was a guy in the movie yeah I
don't really feel like it would have
done I don't think it would have changed
the character oh it would have been
either way it would have been a
different debate it would have been
another man has to help save you know
give powers to Carol Danvers yeah it
just would have been a different
argument at that point you know and and
for some of the films you know more
progressive undertones if it makes a bit
more sense to have her be a woman in
this context and yet to me I mean like I
was kind of aware that yeah they changed
this character some I get why you would
be kind of upset by that if you love the
source material I just I understand that
point of view but yeah I thought it
added to the movie overall and I liked
it and cuz the net betting is great it's
great yeah she's great and even when
she's not being the Marvel character and
just in supreme intelligence role were
by the end of the movie when you know
they've got Carol captured in the
Supreme intelligence world and Annette
Bening is being evil I've really
believed her there too actually
yeah normally like those switching a
villain for who's not like she's not
playing the the villain of it but
switching into villain his position can
be cheesy and not believable but I'm not
betting sells the [ __ ] oh oh yeah cuz
when she's you know real Marvel she has
this very reassuring presence but when
she's the supreme intelligence she has
this cold you know there's like her eyes
have that jaws equality Gary she's got
this like quiet Menace because you know
she's like a supreme you know computer
for someone over Marvel to not be a
fully fleshed out character in this
movie either do you need it I felt like
it was good to get someone like Annette
Bening who can bring an extra layer
because when you look at the script
who's scripting one of the issues we'll
go into later but if you look at the
script especially for Marvel she's not
really a nuanced character in the movie
but and that Betty brings that
additional depth behind every line she
gives in here even in the weirder
moments yeah you know she got her
homework done yeah yeah so what's next
hey this is one of my favorite aspects
of this movie actually and I kind of
shout the trailers out because while I
don't think this movie cut great
trailers I think I'm very forgiving of
that because the reason is there were a
lot of surprises they were hiding and
one of my favorites is what they did
with tailless or Talos tell us yeah I
really enjoyed the way they flipped his
character around I went in expecting a
Ben Mendelsohn to play kind of the same
villainous character he's been typecast
in for a long time now
and yeah the whole reversal with the
scrolls being refugees and the Cree
actually being the oppressors to them
like that is another area of this movie
they you know words with progressive
ideas anyway because refugee situations
are very relevant to the world right now
it's a big issue
I mean Cree being the bad guy isn't
exactly a surprise at this movie
especially coming off of like guardians
and stuff yeah so that that's not a
surprise but flipping the scroll dynamic
I thought was handled really well
because you know if you've seen the e W
first look or any prep leading up to
this movie a lot of people knew that Ben
Mendelsohn was posing as a human would
inside a shield yeah so when you see ben
mendelsohn there were some people who I
can audibly hear people going yeah bad
guys like we never seen Ben Mendelsohn
and then when they give it away when
they have this scroll body in the
autopsy mmm there I've heard a couple
people be like man they give it away
early huh early but that's smart because
by the time you get to the reveal when
they're on a Marie Maria Rambo's house I
that's when his character comes alive
because you hear all these early
reaction comments of Ben Mendelsohn
steals the show Ben Mendelsohn's great
in it and there was like early on in the
film when they're doing like the whole
mine jump moment I didn't I didn't know
I want to go into that a little bit more
later but when they're doing the whole
mine jump moment I didn't know that was
Ben Mendelsohn's voice yeah but I loved
that delivery that was going on of like
rewind that I know it was like that
dialogue delivery on that was so great
and then when you get to the reversal of
it what I thought was neat about Ben
Mendelsohn's performance is that there's
an issue that I've heard with the makeup
and I I halfway agree of the makeup kind
of on the scrolls can make their facial
expressions and now who seemed kind of
stiff and the way they're communicating
I felt like Ben Mendelsohn worked with
that to give a good especially notice
that the second time around to have this
like really dry delivery with the humor
and a calm energy even harsher
situations yeah they have this sort of
endearing quality like you use it to his
advantage I thought for the body
language in the physicality up late
yeah yeah what and that's a kind of
humor too that they bring into these
movies that I do really appreciate
because you gotta imagine that even
though yeah these are intergalactic
creatures and stuff like that you know
they still have a day in day out yeah
there's so many moments with him that
are humorous because they're just small
moments that you don't expect an alien
really care about and and to that the
other half of that is what then happens
with Yann raagh
you know and the you know whole flip
with the Star Force you know basic a
being which we all saw coming yeah but
you know those things I appreciate it
and going back and seeing in a second
time there are a lot of great little
subtleties and nuances in the
performances from both Jude Law and Ben
Mendelsohn that really clue you in and
it's like if you're seen the movie you
know what happens then you can pick up
the little clues yeah time which is
really fun sure like a common complaint
that I hear with this movie and yeah
I'll give it to you guys that they this
movie doesn't do enough of it and maybe
because of time or whatever the story is
at hand they're trying to tell the lack
of exploring the Korean scroll history
of knowing like well I don't know I feel
this so maybe the the flip would have
been more effective on both ends mm-hmm
if there was more of that really
explored and felt absolutely it would
have been more effective for this story
at hand though I thought it was it was
fine yeah yeah I mean cuz the second
time I actually sat and thought well I
mean he's telling a convincing story but
you don't really know what life with the
scrolls is like they could be just as
terrible yeah he's telling you so and
and they do things to alleviate that but
yeah if the movie had more breathing
room to bring you into the history you
might not find yourself wondering that
when such reversals come along and
weirdly when he reunites with his family
on the hidden ship I got a little misty
the second time I watched it I got a
little misty eyed yeah because I I was
expecting it and I understood more of
the character watching in a second time
around so by the time you get to that
point you do feel for him so yeah I do
like that moment and also Jude Law's
yawn rug I think he's real
good in this movie yeah you know a lot
of people kind of just brush him off as
like yeah he's just drew lobbying Jude
Law I wouldn't say that I feel like he's
got a menace
he's layered I love his charisma in the
movie the way he handles a lot of his
lines were my funniest moments for me
comes from a predictable joke when he
when he was uh that final scene it has a
Carol where they're building it up he's
gonna fight him he's gonna fight Carol
and he's roasters yeah I am so we need
to like it was so obvious that he wasn't
gonna fight her like that joke was both
the first time I saw him like oh he's
not going to that's the punchline he's
but the way he handles that delivery
both times got me to laugh really hard
yeah it's just so unexpected and also
his delivery is so great because he's
like yeah for a split second he sounds
like a dad yeah something you know who's
like kids has brought home like an
a-plus on a spelling T goose in this
movie gun I did say in the non-spoiler
that I thought goose was a kid it was
pretty much enriched by the interaction
Sam Jackson has with goose that's that's
how I felt about it cuz it's easy to
have an adorable [ __ ] cat in the
movie yeah that's the Internet but on
the internet cats are what makes it
funny is Nick Fury
[Music]
he's just so all about it and when they
cough lurkin a Fleur Kim yeah that
moment with when he when the floor can
first swallows the tesseract I thought
it was so funny and like the way they
handle the comedic editing of that what
he drops the cat after or I remember the
first time I watched it when it's
attacking all the Kree people on the
ship I really I love that element to it
I thought goose was a delight for me I
don't think goose steals the show
I don't think goose is the best part of
the movie like how some people are
making goose like you I have two cats
I'm a cat lover so yeah do I love goose
sure goes without saying yeah but I
don't think it stills a show I think I
do think the goose element was
effect but see a lot of the lead up to
it though was that that's Carol's cat
that's Carol's cat yeah and I didn't get
any of that in the movie you know yeah
not give two shits about Cathy you know
the cat seems to just kind of be chillin
at Pegasus and then just kind of tags
along after that's essentially it yeah
and and we get the the Nick Fury's eye
explanation out of that you know the
last time I trusted somebody I lost and
he even blatantly I didn't even make
that connection shouts out to Andrew at
the movie source channel cuz yeah he
says I'm trusting you not to eat me oh
my god yeah I got that the first time I
watched it now here's where I'm also
conflicted because they were teasing
that we're gonna learn about what
happens to his eye in this movie I don't
know if it was like in the press leading
up to it if they teased it but early on
in the movie when he gets into a car
crash he has got a messenger like it was
at the moment is that how he lost no
yeah yeah yeah is it gonna happen in
this movie I don't know
and in them I thought this is where I'm
also conflicted I'm kind of with the
audiences on this one who are very much
against that moment because my mind once
I saw when they was when Coulson comes
would be all the eyeballs like oh that
is how he lost his eye yeah in terms of
the context of the one film alone of
Captain Marvel that is funny to me yeah
and it's not out of the realm for me for
him to lie by omission or blatantly lie
he like in Avengers Assemble he'd
flat-out lies about Coulson and would to
get them motivated to work together yeah
he does that so I'm like for him to lie
not a big deal for him to upsell not a
big deal the thing though is my mind
immediately did go to Winter Soldier
because there's a very cool badass
moment in Winter Soldier when he's
talking about the trust a moment and he
reveals the eye and it alludes for an
audience and overall this build-up I'm
not knowing what happens and they don't
lay it out in that movie either but it
you you set yourself up for that most
that's probable but the day we see that
or the day with them that's gonna be a
badass it's got to be like a big [ __ ]
moment be badass or traumatic
jakers yeah and then you get this moment
where they sacrifice that for the
expense of a joke
and in the mousou I'm saying within the
context of the movie itself it's funny
to me like that was funny but overall I
could use I am cut I'm like I am in the
middle ground there where I'm like yeah
it's kind of a letdown and kind of they
sold it out for a Marvel joke but I'm
you you watch the other movie you're
gonna be sitting there going oh yeah
it's not a badass moment anymore yeah I
would probably meet you about there yeah
cuz I'm not gonna watch the movie it's
funny but then when I like think about
the rest and the whole Nick Fury thing I
am I am there with that and I think the
other and there's others big things to
talk about too but I think the other big
one is uh the change in the project
initiative to the Danvers and his
Danvers initiative versus some of a
seamless completing a Carol Danvers even
a team of Carol Danvers
because you don't see what he types and
there are like four words of the the
initiative Carolyn hey we're gonna sing
across the galaxy everyone who has been
hating any of the anything about
feminism to do with this movie or hates
brie Larson or whatever they're not
gonna be happy with that at all I mean I
haven't even looked up with the
responses for everyone who's learned
about that they're not gonna be happy
about it beats yeah yeah I mean I guess
I get why for me it was just a detail I
didn't need it felt like they kind of
just shoved a shoehorned it yeah it's
just like oh okay
I feel like I feel like names come from
everywhere but you know how I mean just
look at our [ __ ] non-spoiler review
or look at half the things people are
like these people are saying you know
like something like for the Avengers to
be named after a woman after Carol
Danvers it doesn't it doesn't matter
like for me personally I'm like I don't
care he just came up with a name like
you know that's for me that's bad
it he purposed a words that's about yeah
for me that's like Carol invented the
word I mean if they're I don't know if
they're gonna drive it home even further
if an end game they bring back Nick Fury
Nick Fury is like I named the Avengers
after you listen to her okay that's a
problem with in some ways yes I could
see being an issue because even though I
did like her more in this movie I do
want to talk a little bit more about my
issues with with with the Carroll in
this movie and the grand scheme of
things but really quick some other stuff
Ronan the accuser wasted in this movie
didn't either tease him at all that he
was in it probably would've been better
if he didn't tease him at being this at
all it would have been less
disappointing because he just stands and
looks at Lando that's my favorite part
is would you LA oh yeah still standing
in that same hologram holding that
hammer waiting for something same pose
the entire movie just waiting but it's
not even like let her ring yeah let me
get my hat and hammer on she's just
waiting for that call oh and really get
the sense that Ronan who just stands by
this one window yeah all the time and
yeah I mean he's periphery at best to
the movie overall I mean there's a
moment where he hints like oh we'll be
back for the weapon yeah you mean the
you know whatever the would be the other
goofy element to me is her name's verse
I don't know in the comics beers of
yours yeah yes I just imagined like when
when they were calling her beers in the
second time watching it I just kept
going
how did that how'd they come to that
name for her in it was when she woke up
it's just like what I just imagine one
of those scenes when someone's like
making up a story and they're like I met
a guy his name was a can just like I
only have her name it's your whole name
now your name is
Viers you're talking about it just
seemed like you couldn't have prepped
something in an answer or where people
like one of those you know I'm talking
about like those like terrible sitcom
jokes
yeah like hey I met a doctor named dr.
shirt I saw that moment when I learned
the name read to me yeah the first time
motivated it is motivated by her dog tag
yeah this is just a made-up words any
one part of this star force seemed like
is that even a name do y'all know what
dog tags does that have a meaning did
you just read half of her name and you
couldn't come up with a name for her
you're a team of soldiers you must have
an equivalent of a dogs yeah you must
have some kind of way of knowing all
this is incomplete yeah what was it like
was it incomplete or dude could he not
come up with a name see this is all we
have now so I got a little too much off
of that here Maria and Monica Rambeau in
this okay yeah it was all the big stuff
right and generally these are all our
things now we'll talk a little bit about
you know female empowerment moments or
they're really in your face there was
that more of an issue with brie Larson
as the person yeah yeah I was there got
some stuff to go through here but yeah I
start with Maria and Monica Rambeau that
I
I love Maria Rambo in this movie yeah I
thought she brought so much of the
necessary history to be felt not like we
need giant exposition dump into all
their training and friendship together
you could see it in the one scene where
she's laying it all out to her about
like no is this strange to me that you
come back with these powers know what's
strange to me is yes you're a whole
other person
you're a whole that personally knew you
you know that yes she thought she was
dead this whole time and and their
dynamic was great and didn't even hit me
until the second time I was watching it
of I feel like some people will harp on
the the feminist elements to this the
the stuff that they felt was very shoved
in their face which I don't honestly
feel like there's a lot of that I don't
really other stuff that could have been
a little more subtly handled
yeah there are a couple fourth wall
breaking jokes like they're like when
the guy tells her like ah you should
smile more like that's about the same
time though that's a real thing women
deal yeah yeah but but that is one of
the more overt instances of something
like that or when she like hits but I
feel like that moments a little more
earn when she went you laws like hit me
fight me find me and then she hits and
says I don't need to prove anything to
you ohto yeah yeah that's that's like
totally core you know yeah feminist idea
you know yeah like I do it but I thought
that's the end of the movie it's earned
let him have it and also I don't also
feel like this movie does anything where
they're saying because first off and
we're gonna talk more about this in the
other video feminism does not mean men
suck feminism is simply equality and
everybody so yeah this movie doesn't
have any angle or agenda of men suck and
that's where I feel like this movie does
none of that so don't worry about it
it's not it's not demeaning to men at
all in this movie the aspects of
feminism that are the most prominent
here I mean a you can take the just the
diversity of the cast as an indicator of
feminine because yeah truthfully I think
the term itself confuses a lot of people
to make it seem like a women versus men
thing but really feminism is just about
equal treatment for people of all races
genders physical abilities ages and
centers yeah and the arc for Captain
Marvel for Carol Danvers is a
self-actualization think she's grown up
in this society that his kind of washed
her brain a certain way and she is
learning to tap into her own strength
her own potential to be independent and
so at the end when she says you know I
don't have to prove anything to you
it feels earned and also if you look at
young rock he is clearly just desperate
and using a different angle because you
know she's got him beat yeah exactly and
that's so for me I'm like there's a lot
of other context behind that moment and
I feel so no there's there was one
moment though yeah because what I loved
in this movie was that there's no love
interest she has and that and that is
not talked about like maybe someone has
I haven't heard it yet I noticed it but
yeah I appreciated it but I didn't bring
it it wasn't until the second
viewing where I'm like they didn't they
didn't go out of their way all to shove
in my face that there's no love interest
in this movie barely missing yeah that's
what I mean that's us that's that's
subtly done and it's and the most kind
of personal love dynamic in any capacity
would be the friendship she has with
Maria Rambo in this movie and I think
that's an important thing to represent
especially to like a female support ship
yeah yeah like because that is a strong
bond and that is something to that has
changed just in culture over time you
know I feel like there was a lot more
pressure years ago and I've heard women
say this you know for women to be at
odds with each other so to have such a
loving friendship between the two and
have that being so much of the emotional
core of the movie means you still get
the the woman a table at each other with
the Jemma Chan character but even then
you understand because there are
ideologies and and and she just doesn't
like her yeah and I do want to touch on
that because this isn't like responding
to a comment there was one moment where
I had where I genuinely had to catch my
mail thought process and what I've been
preconditioned to there's a really it's
it's a cool first off it's just it is a
very corny scene you know but guys in
there above a dude in a go boy and I
find it just as equally corny it's the
moment where she's like trying to figure
out what her suit is and Monica is like
playing around and trying to find the
right colors and stuff and it it's at
such a corny superhero moment and my
mind did go as a dude is my liam neeson
mobis female but I checked myself like
right away it was I was like other
they're really doing that whole thing
for like something for little girls to
look up to the future generation yeah
that's that's for my mind when but then
I immediately once I thought that I went
well Iron Man 3 had a whole thing about
a little boy an Iron Man and their
bonnets I got a big part of the movie
and the inspiration there and then
there's other elements of that in other
comic book movies were little boy he's
you know so why not have it with a
little girl this time around yeah start
to think to yourself you know little
boys are probably gonna see this movie
identify with that kid and feel special
about it so why can't a little girl have
that - yeah exactly yeah but my mind did
have that I would probably consider that
a precondition sexist thought because I
was like they're shoving this in my face
now but wait a minute when they do with
little boys I don't even think about
that's like she and Monica also do have
a relationship we see some flashbacks
and when Carol gets to the house it's
Monica who's filling around this is what
you did this time yeah Halloween costume
and like clearly there's there's yeah
the only issue with that is that when
she picks the color she just
automatically knows how to do it yeah
but I didn't even talk about who did
talk about the made her post credit
scene so she kills Thanos in the
mid-credits scene
yeah so the we find out what happens
when that pager goes off so so the mid
the mid-credits scene looks like it's
just a CNN event game it does it has
literally died and probably a cut up
scene because they did that with ant
they did that with ant-man and then they
showed a scene from Civil War but they
edited it down and it feels like they
probably did an edited down version
people love that scene they think it's
like it's such a badass moment it is a
badass moment for me I always read it as
a horror movie moment every time it
happens it's like a jump-scare should
you come from where's fury see the thing
about this movie that this raises
questions in a lot of ways of timeline
lineage where's Captain Marvel Ben it
makes you wonder like yeah when I look
at this as a standalone movie it's fine
when I look at this in the Greater grand
scheme of things it's kind it does be
racist questions
yeah of okay if Nick Fury was worried
about intergalactic space travel there
are people attacking or whatever and
encountered aliens makes you flash back
to Avengers Assemble like
why didn't he call Carol then no yeah
yeah why why did everyone seemed
unprepared for this if this happened in
the 90s Jean are already is two supers
and like a pretty damn powerful wanted
that yeah the whole thing with the
tesseract I'm not I actually kind of
lose track of those things with the
tesseract to be perfectly honest yeah
because I know that was in Captain
America that's sorry oh she had said the
ocean it appears that the post-credits
scene of Thor yeah you know so I'm like
for me I kind of like whatever I'm not
so hung up on that edge I'm I am more in
the prequel syndrome because it's not a
prequel but it takes place in the past
so I am caught up in that thing of well
why didn't they do this why didn't they
call Carol before there's been plenty of
it this is really probably should have
called Carol but maybe maybe they
thought we have Thor on our hands or you
know like there are certain debate
moments that happen in Avengers
specifically that one where I go you
should have been prepared then or you
should have called Carol yeah and this
is this is a greater issue just with
shared universe comic book films overall
to me is I feel like it's very easy
especially the more powerful a character
is to just start going well why they
just call that guy and oh yeah not the
Avengers movies the MCU in general has
this problem yeah so totally it's not
just a Captain Marvel problem like there
are so many times you're like why don't
you call the Avengers yeah like lower
tier people dealing with this matter
exactly these guys would just do it in
like 20 minutes plenty of times or even
like why don't you assemble the team you
know yeah and so I guess you're just
left to go maybe she was just so busy
with so many other things just oh yeah
is one of those plot holes that you
don't really know what to do with and
for all these people who just want us to
hate this movie here you go I'm gonna go
into my script and acting problems with
the film all right
the things that I do have real issues
with in terms of how its executed
Carol's Arc the first time I watched it
I didn't even really realize she had an
arc honestly I did
I was like it kind of so much is
happening there's a lot of mumbo-jumbo
that I was like I just there's an
archetype flew past me to me it just
seemed like she just kept getting
stronger and more undefeatable the movie
went and then it hit me more this time
around like oh I see it now the thing is
her art script wise is not set up well
in this movie with it
I didn't realize where her I feel like
for an arc it's okay to have an arc a
either be predictable or at least hint
at what the potential of an arc is going
to be in this movie I don't even know
what arcs gonna be until a moment before
the arc happens and that's not because
they cleverly subtly hit it I just
personally don't think it's executed
well where she's talking with the
supreme intelligence she's talking that
Bening you know in that moment and
you're like we gave you the powers we
made you a better version of yourself
and the thing is I don't feel any of
Carol Danvers prior struggles before her
getting the energy and its kind of all
being laid out like they teased it early
on when they're doing like the mine
[ __ ] moment of your a woman in the
the Air Force pilot or why are you here
people are always under estimating you
and you're always proving you're tough
as nails basically as a lot of her
backstory but I didn't really feel that
backstory was properly explored enough
in a way where I could have really felt
for that arc or have possibly seen that
aren't coming to the point where when
that arc happens it feels like a truly
rewarding empowering moment for Carol
Danvers as opposed to when they're doing
that montage of the many times Carol
stands up the same exact way every
single moment the same stand same pose
which is a cool visual thing but when
that happens I'm like okay I guess
that's what her arc is that's kind of
how it read to me in the moment as
opposed to me feeling front because she
doesn't struggle in this movie that's
that's the thing that happens is like
she there's no real weaknesses
emotionally that are truly presented
other than some moments of expositional
dialog here in the film oh my gosh I
keep going I mean I can't jump it I just
want to make sure you were at a resting
point well to me her art hers her
emotional journey really doesn't begin
until she gets the files at Pegasus hmm
where she starts going oh [ __ ] my past
is linked here and then she's on the
telephone with Yan raagh I know for sure
my past is here I see her she's getting
a little misty-eyed and this she's being
told to repress her emotions yeah if the
movie doubled down more on those kind of
elements because that one thing I talked
about my non-spoiler there was I felt
this should have been and it's like okay
on the surface she has to be emotionless
but there's got to be something ordered
something likes some desk
I said Wonder Woman meets Jessica Jones
you know have that depth underneath of
like her humor and sarcasm stems from
that all this repression or whatever you
know and then in that moment you get it
you get that tease and then that's why
by the time you get to the more she
hears the black box recording and all
all the memories come back I don't even
know who I am and then all that could
have been teetered out a little bit
better I don't think the arc when you
get to that moment it's like there's an
arc here I don't think script wise it's
built to it well is what I'll say that's
fair I I'm torn on this personally
because especially talking after the
first viewing I definitely think that it
is a valid criticism of this movie that
a lot of the personal stuff with Carol
is handled through other characters kind
of outside of her yeah like Maria saying
you're stronger before man I'm like but
I don't I never saw any of that yeah for
my viewing experience of this movie and
just as an element
amid the medley of elements the movie is
trying to achieve both times I wasn't
really bothered by the handling of Carol
Danvers and watching it the second time
I did find that they're not prolonged
moments a lot of the time but I thought
that they did actually have intimate
moments with Carol
they are kind of subdued and I can
understand totally why somebody would be
kind of less than connected to her if
you're viewing the movie a certain way
but for me I found it compelling because
yeah you're watching her brain
out of an indoctrinated state of mind
you know your forgive me but you know
you're watching her kind of become woke
to the idea that she has been sort of
again brainwashed into a certain
scenario she is learning to embrace
herself in her power and and learn to
stand on her own to think for herself
but also I enjoyed that they made her
origin story not just how she got her
powers but who she is part of the goal
of the movie so that as the movie is
going forward and she's trying to you
know basically complete her mission on
earth that's the plot mission she's also
trying to find out more about who she is
and that is something that sets in
overtime because you know during the
course the movie she learns oh this this
life on hala is not my actual life you
know and now I'm finally going to get
some answers to the question marks it's
like she doesn't have that much history
she's only got six years worth of
memories when we start the movie and
she's constantly being coached to keep
her emotions in check so with all those
details in mind from my own viewing
experience again I actually had a fine
time connecting with her both viewings
but I also do think it's a very valid
criticism that she could have used more
personal moments to herself as opposed
to through other people well if you're
not gonna give her any real external
struggles throughout the film you got to
give her more internal struggles and
less more showing less telling
intermittently because that's the thing
is like that's all they're what you're
talking about but it's just told to you
at certain chunks in certain scenes as
opposed to properly like pacing it out
or fleshing it out throughout the thing
cuz it's all there I just mean it's an
issue of execution and there are some
certain acting scenes that I really just
do not click with brie Larson in this
movie I thought she was better - the
second time I watched her there's
certain choices like the the scene that
really flashes to mind to me that that I
just really do not like I don't know if
it's directing or just her acting
because it's sort of like I don't think
it could be maybe it's a script it's the
scene when Marvel when they're over
there at listen to the black box
then [ __ ] crashes down and at that
level of high intensity in a space
battle you've never had before you know
she's so nonchalant and so calm about
everything they crash there's like no
pulse pounding I'm like no no your
adrenaline would be pump out here who
like this is your first time experience
this you're generally be pumping right
now and she comes out and sees freaking
Marvel and you're like your blood is
blue oh and then pulls her down I'm
gonna you know I find it weird that
you're an alien but you know after
everything it's just so like nonchalant
about it I'm like no this is this is
poor whatever it is I don't think brie
Larson is a queer actually not an
important choice it's poor choices right
here which goes hand in hand with a lot
of the lack of stakes that happened
throughout the film I feel because
that's what I mean like none of the
internal like those moments could have
really elevated a lot of this this film
because not having enough of physical
threats you know like I think there's a
moment that a lot of people are very
back and forth on which is the what's
that what's the song that plays where
she's like when she unleashes her powers
and she's fighting Ella star force oh no
doubt I'm just a girl yeah yeah okay
that that scene I like the way it's cut
I do I think it's fun i I think that
star force they could have done a better
job scripting wise visual if they showed
us at all what makes no cuz like their
moments are they tease like oh dude he's
got the sword the guy with the [ __ ]
like just lightsaber gloves or whatever
good like they're a cool horror like you
could have set this up where it could
have seemed like a challenge in some
capacity for her to fight these ultimate
warriors but that's never demonstrated
so one part of me is like this is really
fun the other part of me is there's no
tension at all and in these fights I
just I understand
again but especially the second time
that particular fight with that
particular music cue clicked with me
because of where it fell and because of
what happened after because she fights
the rest
of the star force sands yon rug in that
sequence what she's just fully realized
herself she's fully unlocked her power
and she's about to go kick some ass and
I thought it was appropriate there
because at that moment I was like I
don't think this is gonna be the fight
in the structure that she's about to
lose and when it changes shape when it
goes beyond that moment you do get score
music for the rest of the fight when she
goes up against jewel on so in that
moment I was like yeah I think it's
appropriate for this to be fun and cool
because then later it'll get more heavy
and more traditional in the movie sense
and that's a moment where you never
become heavy that's the thing it seems
like whatever likes because that's
another issue is that she when she gets
her powers part of the fun of like
Marvel origin characters is when they're
learning how to use their powers and in
here she kind of just she's never flown
you know she's never done these likes
the most she's done it and she has some
fight skills but she's doing all kinds
of [ __ ] [ __ ] you Billy
like she's handling [ __ ] like it's no
that's what I mean like not one fight in
there is there tension for her I mean
like Yann rocks for a brief second gets
a little bit of a handle on her when she
puts her up against the wall on the one
but she really overpowers you know yeah
missiles are coming from Ronan yeah one
and two I think perhaps for me just a
lot of the thrust of the fights is from
how punchy they are just assembled
physically I thought it's entertaining
as [ __ ] yeah there's no tension yeah
yeah and so this is another part of this
movie where I'm like it really worked
for me but that's a very fair criticism
yeah it's like for my whatever you know
arrangement of levels I was taking this
in it I thought that was appropriate but
but yeah yeah I mean see I'm I could I
have used more weight through brie
Larson's portrayal from the writing and
acting absolutely I really could have
because it's kind of weird how the like
my main takeaways are the things I
really talk about in love or never look
what's the little module brie Larson in
his movie you know and like a lot of
it's like the supporting cast in
everything yeah
and cuz that but the thing is another
reason why I recommend is because there
are plenty of cool very visual pallet
scenes in here that I really that whole
time with the mine sequence when that
movie first get there both times I've
watched I [ __ ] love that moment the
way the dialogue is handled in the
background with Talos and then the way
the sequence is playing out with like
the with Marvel going it like the recur
redoing the memory over and over again
to get the name on the tag it's so
disconcerting and then you sort of have
to orient yourself and figure out what
they're doing or what she's my creative
sequences or she like flies from the
plane up and it's thrown back down like
it Jack's
yeah forcing her to live in the memory
yeah yeah I like managing her mind in
some yeah right place they need like
that's great the the effects would like
to Supreme intelligence in that world
building to I thought was really well
done and so like I love that Johanna she
punches her in the mouth and goes
through throws over against the wall and
it's like the mirror from the matrix I
yeah yeah like the mix of worlds and
space sequences I think are all really
cool like I love when she first gets in
the ship and like when she when she's
escaping the squirrel ship and she's
that one shot and everything behind her
that's some really cool stuff work the
moment when she gets hit with the energy
blast
that's like beautifully in 4dx create a
screen screen X that's great yeah but
even in regular format that's great it's
notify and it's one of those marvels
slo-mo like it looks like a painting
kind of shots yeah it's a great moment
uh so I I feel like their life from
humor entertainment connection maybe I
don't connect with Carol but I connect
with the supporting cast and that's like
well there's plenty enough here to
really record like why I find it fun and
I liked her more the second time is she
not she the least strong out of all the
performers for me in this movie yes but
I feel like there's a lot of performers
you know yeah and also you know it's
like a couple of minor problems I have
with the film here there too like one
moment I really like is when Agent
Coulson is in the car with Sam Jackson
the chase hmm and then and then it finds
out that that's of a scroll yeah I
thought that's a that's a cool like oh
that's a cool moment yeah but second
time around I was like why does this
girl have a gun
my mind the second time I watch it goes
when would this switcheroo have happened
exactly well like okay whatever I didn't
see it it happened off screen I could
buy that all right whatever but then he
pulls out a handgun and I'm like wait
about what are the powers of the can
they replicate a handgun did he let a
handgun hey box or something wait a
minute we're at the hand gonna come from
like little things like that yeah or or
when they get in the crash and then the
police start showing up and you hear
them off-screen thing and then Sam
Jackson pulls out his badge and it's
like it's like a it's like a cinemasins
moment I'm just like official shield
activity I'm like but they're in their
car of driving they can't hear him I'm
like it's a movie thing you had a thing
about them going to space truthfully I
especially seeing this the second time
around you know I went in because of all
the controversy I was like alright I'm
just gonna take this as license to test
my original experience and I found
through this movie that I pretty much
just yeah I just liked all the stuff
that I liked the first time but both
times the moment where they have the
debate about Maria going on the journey
just doesn't work for me and I think
that is one example of a plot point that
I think is just kind of lazy to get us
to point B because every both times I've
seen it when you know Monica makes the
case of like you know but you used to go
and fly these these test planes of this
your passion and both times my mind
filled in the blank with but that was
before I had a human child to be
responsible for and she's like what kind
of example are you setting for your
daughter and I'm like I guess one where
you leave your daughter and go fight a
dangerous space mission where you could
easily die I have an argument for you
though okay
please if it was gender reversed
I just don't think like the kid
convincing the parent and the parent
just stopping there and being like well
my kid wants me to go it's a lazy plot
point
it's lazy maneuver honestly and it's
really poorly handled it should have
been more of a debate in a moment it
just didn't can you ask me yeah yeah no
I like that it could have worked if
there wasn't just like a couple of lines
yeah that scene it had an actual debate
instead of addressing the debate
and then just skipping to a very brittle
belly
yeah 90s Joe kind of a manipulative plot
point where it's the kids idea so it's
okay but you know that that kind of
bugged me but and I didn't notice the
second time around the 90s nostalgia
stuff isn't as shoved in your face as I
thought it was it's just there are
certain audience members when you who
would anything 90s at all I'm like this
is how people when they watch movies
that are based in the 70s who were
boarded the seventies react people
Apelles
bell-bottoms I'm like it's not that
funny
just cuz there's a that's a 90s thing
it's just
yeah I found myself in audience members
you make it a no I found myself enjoying
those gags when the crowd wasn't losing
their [ __ ] like it was it was I
flashback the first screening I
flashback to like one of those parody
movies where the joke is like look it's
a person we recognize and that's the
joke and I was like oh yeah look an
internet cafe tada
but yeah those moments do I think I go
down better when you know just not
everyone's treating them like they're
the most inspired comes yeah yeah cuz
they're to be expected and they're cute
you know
well guys yeah I mean overall I don't
think it's one of Marvel's Marvel's had
a lot of movies I don't think it's more
their top five or I probably put another
top ten but when I say that like I liked
it the first time the second time I
really liked it I'm not in love with
this movie but I think it's a very very
very enjoyable movie like like so much
you know and do I think you should watch
this over a leader if you watch Elita
over this just go watch bunch of em both
I recommend both these movies yeah I
think elite is good and I like Aleta and
I like I feel like Aelita has flaws but
I liked it and I recommended Captain
Marvel same thing there were flaws yeah
do I like it yes like they're both fine
just go go watch them they're both good
go [ __ ] enjoy yourself yeah I mean
for me like once I cash my check from
Marvel i I
really enjoyed this film and this like I
honestly I enjoyed the film the first
time kind of in most respects and the
second time I had kind of the same
experience I was just like I really like
this I think everything there are things
that could be improved but I think it's
really tight it's really creative it
bends a lot of worlds and genres it has
so many things going for it and for me
personally just my own taste of the
Marvel films this is one I think that is
going to sit closer to the top maybe not
top 5 but sit in a place where it is
more memorable to me than some of the
other ones because I do think it has
some distinct qualities that then like
it deserves people were like finally a
non-biased review I was kind of taking
it back by that cuz I'm like courses
non-biased
and then I then I realized after looking
so much up which we'll talk about in the
next one the next video now it's like oh
damn there was this whole thing I did
not follow who it was like there are
only things I like I heard hints about
with the controversy behind this movie
leading up to it then I just did not pay
attention to cuz I am NOT someone who
really engages on the social media rage
well if so I I just I missed out on it's
so like going into this the the amount
of it the amount of hate we got for not
hating this movie threw me for a loop
yeah then I looked into it I'm like oh
this makes a lot more sense now yeah and
and it's it's something that I've come
to be very wary about big movies because
of you know because with a movie like
this especially and from a critical
standpoint it's kind of hard to walk in
to your first viewing of a Captain
Marvel when you have all of this stuff
kind of swarming around your head and I
feel like that can easily hamper the
experience and make you self-conscious
and you have all these ideas and weirdly
enough as much as I was aware of the
conversation it didn't really affect my
viewing the first time and I'm I
appreciate that but yeah there's been
some undue ugliness around this movie
that really bums me out because I don't
think it's necessary at all and I don't
think it's warranted I hope this movie
makes a gajillion dollars yeah I mean
like I don't love it to the degree I
don't look I don't want to make a
gajillion dollars for that fact I wanted
to make a good jillion dollars
and to fly in the face of people who
come in and just treat you like it's
impossible to actually have just enjoyed
this movie yeah you can't fathom that
authentically somebody could just have a
different opinion yeah like I feel like
it was funny cuz when the first
screening ended I was seeing they're
going yeah we all had a great time right
guys and then like everybody was mixed
on it and so I was like oh yeah I don't
want to say like this movie was met with
applause the first time we watch it
because people will be like greeting
yeah we saw this since we saw this with
it's just a regular crowd last night and
you know what it was met with applause
quite a few times so we're into it yeah
people were really when it when when the
movie ended applause when it said Carol
Danvers we'll return it in Avengers end
game applause it you know like so [ __ ]
yeah like you if you're one of the
people who just like was boycotting this
for whatever agenda you got fine be that
way as this stands for a movie on its
own like I think for for the female
audience and the female that like I
think yeah whatever moved to dudes
we like this movie yeah yeah I honestly
if you can't relate to a female
superhero
I I don't know how to help you because
there's so much male characters to enjoy
too what guys yeah the magic I think
part of the true magic of feminism is
you look at a movie like this and you're
like man woman most of these roles you
could have swapped the genders and it
wouldn't matter like that's the great
thing about Marvel is like yes they made
her a woman it's not necessarily that
way in the original version of the story
but it doesn't really change the
character that much yeah you know or you
know it doesn't make it intrinsically
female somehow yeah and I like it she's
just an actress playing the role she
does a great job playing Oh guys
subscribe rejects click the notification
about these three Captain Marvel videos
are gonna cause us to lose so many subs
but I'd rather wean them out
if you're about to just sign on ik the
slackers SJ driver counsels don't make
[ __ ] no mean [ __ ] to be any more about
that and let's catch you guys later